بعد جائحه كورونا وما رافقها من تداعيات
اقتصاديه قاسيه تراجعت اسهم شركات
تكنولوجيا وبدات تفقدوا بريقها وموظفيها
معا نستطيع القول لانها دخلت غرفه الانعاش
في الاشهر الاخيره وكثير منها بدا مرحله
الاحتضار الى ان تدخل الذكاء الاصطناعي
ومنحها قبله الحياه وقادها لفتره وجيزه
الى طفره هائله اصبح من المستحيل تقريبا
تجاهلها او الهروب منها فذكاء الاصطناعي
هو المجال الوحيد الذي ما زال يجذب موظفين
جدد بوادي السيليكون كما تقول واشنطن بوست
فتقرير بيانات شركه بيتش بوك المتخصصه ان
راس المال المستثمر في هذا النوع من
الشركات زاد سته وثمانين في المئه عن ذات
الشهر من العام الماضي الاسبوع الماضي
اصبحت شركه انفيديا التي تصنع رقائق ذكيه
اصبحت واحده من عدد قليل من الشركات في
العالم التي بلغت قيمتها تريليون دولار
واشنطن بوست ترى ان اندفاع شركات
الاستثمار في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي جاء
بعد اطلاق شركه اوبن اي اي لبرنامج
الروبوت الذكي دفع شركات تكنولوجيا
العملاقه مثل مايكروسوفت وجوجل لدخول
السباق وبالمقارنه بينما تم استثماره في
شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا العام وما
استثمر سابقا نجد الفجوه هائله فاثنى عشر
فاصله خمسه مليار دولار تم استثمارها هذا
العام حتى الان مقارنه باربعه فاصله خمسه
مليار دولار فقط تم استثمارها في هذا
المجال عام 2022
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات